B c'est au pied du mur que on voit le
maçon donc moi j'attends de voir ce que
sera le texte mais si le texte reprend
ce que l'on pouvait trouver dans dans
dans les tractes du rassemblement
national ou de la droite extrême la plus
dure ça veut dire que les Diges ont
sauté et ça veut dire que il y a plus de
canal historique il y a plus de canal
officiel il y a juste un pays qui comme
d'autres pays de Europe est en train de
dériver voilà vous allez déposer moet si
en cas de CMP conclusive en cas de CMP
conclusive bien sûr nous déposerons une
motion de rejet et au cas où le vote
serait majoritaire nous feront tout pour
qu'il y ait un recours au Conseil
constitutionnel sur plusieurs aspects de
la loi et et on continuera de se battre
dans l'intérêt de la France de notre
pays et des valeurs de la République
fraternité égalité liberté
voilà